the federal response to the Ohio train
derailment has been an absolute disgrace
from the start mayor peed our Intrepid
Transportation secretary has gone
through the three stages of
mckinsey-style coping first he treated
it as kind of a joke even making a
balloon reference then he treated it as
an inconvenience noting how busy his
time is his Transportation ahead and
finally he claimed it was really just a
minimal disruption since there are a
thousand derailments every year
well second there's FEMA they just
turned down a request for federal
Disaster Assistance from Ohio Governor
Mike dewine how long until we get the
this era's version of heck of a job
brownie and finally there's the EPA
administer Michael Regan he finally
graced the suffering people of East
Palestine with his presence yesterday
and given his back and forth with Bill
hemmer this morning uh don't think the
residents there are feeling very
comforted
I'm thankful for the Emergency
responders including my EPA staff that
were on the ground hours after the trail
derailment when you bring in a senior
official especially at the cabinet level
you divert or pull away resources from
the emergency response we've been there
since day one I want to stress we've
been there since day one
okay that was bad
I should have watched the whole thing
but surely we could reliably you know
get someone to inform the people of East
Palestine about whether the water coming
from their faucets was okay to drink
right is the water safe
you know I trust Governor dewine if your
water has been tested by the state we
believe it is safe to drink are you
saying it's safe or do you know
the drinking water is safe for those
homes that have been tested and the data
proves that those homes are are safe
continue to drink bottled water until
you get that that approval or that green
light from the state
okay this is just ridiculous joining me
now Florida Congressman Byron Donalds
member of the House oversight committee
boy do we need oversight here
congressman
will there be an inquiry into this
Federal response this FEMA administrator
is in way over his head clearly he's
uncomfortable with these questions and
you know I don't they used to always
take the covid shots remember to
convince people that the that the MRNA
shot was safe but I don't see him
drinking the water
oh God first thing I'll tell you is I
think there is going to be congressional
oversight because watching this tragedy
unfold over East Palestine and the just
not even the lack of response but the
ineptitude of the response demonstrates
that Congress needs to figure out
exactly what's going on oh listen
everybody knows about what happened to
my district back during Hurricane Ian
and obviously you saw everybody show up
and try to give their helping hand but
what's happened in Ohio has been a
disaster where is EPA where is FEMA
where is the White House they're barely
even acknowledging this thing and let's
not even start with Pete butterjudge
that man needs to needs to go he's
proven that he is a net in his job
well uh should we trust the government
because the EPA administrator said
people just you know have to calm down I
understand why you're upset but trust
the government should have they been
given given people reason to trust them
no they have not and in these scenarios
nobody wants to hear trust they want to
verify that actions are being taken how
do you do that you do that with local
officials State officials and federal
officials all working in coordination
everybody's got to forget their politics
tie the hands and get the job done
you've not seen this in in the response
that's happened so far and so for them
to show up late to the game saying that
oh we're finally going to send Health
officials from HHS the EPA administrator
is you know on the on the zoom link he's
not there on the ground seeing firsthand
what his staff is doing and making sure
they're working in concert with the
state of Ohio that's a terrible response
something that can't be tolerated
man we really appreciate it thank you so
much tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else